hello and welcome to this video playing
pocket i F flat okay so what do we get
Oh Adelaide c3 sicyon okay huh it's a
little bit uncommon I know but it's an
interesting line let's see what he does
I had this underwater only recently with
I'm taking him okay hmm
a g6 is smooth yeah I don't know but
taking is usually the critical move so
it's just them develop do this first and
see where he's going now Bishop d2 okay
doesn't look very harmonious the cell so
let's say I take a teeny and play play
what Bishop h6 could be an idea in some
cases
and I just let's develop I mean what is
this next move they are king a king si -
maybe yep
plate that one
hmm let's do this
IDs Knight to d7 which would gain the
pawn back because of the Knight takes
before a threat okay so his is preparing
that it seems if I call Knight to e5
here and yes - go F form I don't don't
really see how to continue from from
there maybe I'm too concerned and simply
should develop like I mean he doesn't
have a very harmonious position I'm
thinking about ways to get the pawn back
but maybe this is really not what this
is all about yeah this is kind of useful
anyway
yeah but still have the same who does he
get this developed in some ammonia's way
it's not easy I didn't know if you would
wait I shouldn't take with the rook
automatically taking with the pawn and
then playing d4 is actually quite
interesting yeah this is actually strong
I think because it makes sure that this
bishop is finally playing
okay so she takes a double attack maybe
he's got tonight no night move no it
wouldn't have helped all that much
anyway if I take F to a 90 force is a
concern really in Nazi form
yeah not overly happy with how this
turned out
yeah something 96 is good but he's gotta
Knight f6 which not totally clear to me
I have this check but he's got his his
he has invasion ideas himself he can now
make a draw with 95 but maybe yes more
95 King bee 796 is the draw but maybe he
can play for win
Ruki seven i have to go back I see six
there came the song okay um yeah where
do we go I have to go here I can't if I
check him I mean you know I'm in a
self-penned now so I'm clearly were
seeing great yeah I must have made
something must have done something quite
stupid here the position was certainly
very good for me yeah unfortunately I
mean II just blundered the piece but
it's unfortunately not clear anyway it's
got its got this pawns
yeah I think I'm just lost
it's doing everything to spoilage but
what a sick game what a sick game that
made no sense for in any shape or form
yeah well a blitz chess yeah what I
really want is I mean this position yeah
I cannot quite believe that I shouldn't
be okay at least and the way it turned
out I mean let's not look at everything
a bit like here
shouldn't that be fine yeah after Bishop
takes so rook takes is still better
young yeah isn't it good somehow maybe
it is on yeah Timmy cake I took with the
dishes I mean the way it shape turned
out probably rook takes a stronger but I
am 94 and then f5 actually I mean it's
I'm not I'm not better he or anything
but this is BAE at least to prove them
okay and you can argue that I can play
stuff for when you're with the better
structure but okay it's draw maybe this
is better then I mean this really was
kind of uncomfortable to say the least
yeah idea I'm just lost I guess 95
what's the deal seven king de and I just
just the game is winning okay yeah I
mean I thought like the kid was giving
less plastic class for okay the game is
very much winning I was thinking okay
there maybe there was something better
even yeah now i okay be blundered that
piece but it's still going to be very
difficult to play and somehow somehow
you managed to to to screw that up give
me seven and now you just have to push
the pawns I mean that's also still
should win b5 now I'm winning him yeah
that's what I thought b5 still saves
okay so Bishop f4 I have to play for a
hooked one okay
it's difficult b6 is to draw somehow
just about b6 there should be five and
then King to b7 yeah yeah because here I
know it walks over to the other side
ah wow this is very difficult
that's very difficult because those
points are also very vulnerable okay
yeah and then this just was losing Lenya
picking picking up everything what a
weird game really okay guys thanks for
watching